[Music]  these two spectacular temples sit in  China's most biodiverse mountain range  and you may have to pass through the  clouds to reach its peak fangy shan is  located in china's glacial province and  is the highest mountain of the Wulin  mountain range the tallest peak stands  about eight thousand feet above sea  level and is believed to have formed  between 2 million and 65 million years  ago one of the most well known features  affine jing shan is red cloud golden  summit and the two temples sit on its  peak which are connected by a stunning  and heart-pounding  narrow bridge benjin Shan has been a  sacred place for centuries and it  remains an important pilgrimage site for  Buddhist worshipers around the world  in 2012 plunging Shan was named the 13th  UNESCO natural heritage site in China  securing China's top spot at having more  Natural Heritage Sites than any other  country  [Music]